bon un homo bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors la première
question comment vous avez accueilli
cette demande de pardon au nom de la
france dans la bouche des venelles
macron
d'abord il n'y avait pas de notre part
une demande de pardon parce que je crois
que ça ne sert à rien de demander à
l'état de demander pardon aux des choses
qui vous font sont impardonnables mais
le fait que le président le faz au nom
du coût de la population française de la
nation française puisque c'est bien un
président en exercice
il le fait celle ci ne peut évidemment
quatre ans bien accueilli mais très
franchement je crois qu'il faut pas se
polariser sur la demande de pardon
l'important c'est la volonté du
président de la république de présenter
un projet de loi que le gouvernement
dans un projet de loi avant la fin de
l'année civile
c'est ça que tu est important et je suis
content demandé est ce que vous vous
étonnez que cette reconnaissance
que ce pardon que ce projet de loi
arrive aussi tard
moi je tendance à dire mieux vaut tard
que jamais écoutez les présidents
précédents ont effectivement
reconnu la faute de l'état ont reconnu
la responsabilité de l'état dans
l'abandon des harkis les personnes est
allée jusqu'à aller gravé dans le marbre
de la loi donc moi je lis fait
pleinement qu'ils annoncent maintenant
et quand j'entends des leaders
politiques commencé à dire
si c'est de l'électorat lille il faut
être sérieux il ya une élection à chaque
année en france donc s'il allait sheila
de galère ou alix et pour les régionales
avant noël dit que j'étais pour les
européennes non il faut arrêter ça fait
vieux con sera basé sur ce dossier
depuis longtemps c'est tout vous dire
que ça fait déjà au moins deux ans que
le président de la république voulait
aller plus loin simplement ça nous a pas
échappé il ya comme un lieu la fiche
aliker
qui affectivement s'annonce
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de ce
projet de loi et de ce fonds de
réparation à l'égard des harkis une
étape nécessaire on l'imaginait ce que
c'est suffisant selon vous il faut
encore aller plus loin
je vois pas antoine et plus loin
la logique que simplement il faut les
faits maintenant la logique se dérouler
et évidemment être vigilant pour bien
vérifier qu'elles se déroulent bien
supérieur à reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'état les appels
nombre de manquements évidents reconnu
les états de 62 n'a pas agi avec
responsabilité avec humanité avec
fraternité
donc il faut acter sa partant de là
quand on est responsable des dommages
il faut évaluer le préjudice est de
réparer temple voilà donc il faut il
faut aller se garer trois étapes quel
était l'état d'esprit ce matin
dr qui justement après cette rencontre
avec avec le chef de l'état
moi j'ai envie de bien 40 par l'état
d'esprit d'après fallait il faut pas les
esprits il est l esprit d'avant avant il
y avait beaucoup de scepticisme c'est à
dire que les gens et à juste raison
d'ailleurs se disait il n'ira pas
jusqu'à la loi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'application il ya beaucoup d'impact
diplomatique financier psychologie
politique et puis parce que à l'évidence
le calendrier législatif est très serré
et ceci dit s'il a laissé place à de la
satisfaction la victoire mais avec vie
d'avant chez certains toujours
le besoin de rester prudente parce que
ce que la loi déjà voté donc on sait pas
ce qu'il y aura dedans la commission
évidemment des pas constitué c'est pas
qu'il a constituera comment elle
travaillera c'est le fonds
d'indemnisation on a rendu à quelle
hauteur il sera à bondues donc une
comptant sur le fond et et vigilance
maintenant pour la suite et qu'est ce
que vous attendez justement de de cette
loi à venir
c'est ce que je viens de vous dire tout
simplement la reconnaissance officielle
par les représentants de la nation à
l'unanimité j'espère parce que c'est
vraiment un suivi de dépasser les
querelles trans partis veulent donc une
loi qui ont reconnu sans ces manquements
de l'état car mais à la nation de se
regarder à nouveau en phase mais se rend
concilier avec son histoire avec toutes
ses composantes
de permettre une sorte de résilience
collectif et que de rentrer dans une
logique de vérité de justice jusque là
on était dans des logiques d'assistanat
de solidarité
merci beaucoup monde à vous d'avoir est
avec nous ce soir je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association agir
pour l'air qui merci beaucoup